sunny is in Arizona at Dave Ramsey
dot-com he says I'm 23 years old I'm
saving to pay cash for my first house
cool how do I respond to people when
they make fun of me or tell me that it
can't be done just a smile at them in a
wink because you're looking at an idiot
there's all kinds of normal people out
there that tell you that you could
greatness can't be done
greatness can't be achieved the number
of people that told me we would never
succeed in radio that are no longer in
radio and I'm in to Hall of Fame's you
know it's amazing the number of people
told me I couldn't make it in radio and
the number of people in your family that
tell you you're not going to make it the
number of people that are supposed
friends oh don't do that yeah it's gonna
be harder you know you want to do what
you want to self-publish a book what I
did sold 145 thousand I'm a publisher
came along gave me a lot of money for
that book you know it worked out okay
that one sold over three million copies
now worked out okay lots of people told
me it couldn't be done I mean I had one
guy tell me he said you know no we don't
need another get out of debt look
there's a get out of that debt book on
every shelf in every bookstore America
needs another get out of debt book like
Oprah needs another diet book publishing
guy told me that at lunch I said you
know you're probably right but I just
had this thing inside of me God said do
that book and so I didn't even know how
to write a book I'm sore I'm horrible
writer I'm a great communicator but I'm
not a very good writer I mean I destroy
the English language my freshmen
compensation compensation composition
see I can't even say the word
composition Ted you're my freshman essay
teacher my freshman English teacher slit
her wrists bled all over my paper was
all read you know just like you're not
going to make it son you don't know the
English language you're a redneck
hillbilly you don't know anything and
fifteen million books later I guess it's
worked out you know so honey when people
tell you can't do something that's just
a really good reason to write it down
and remember all that then later when
you see of you can just smile sometimes
the best revenge you can get on stuff
like that is just go be successful so
there's all kinds of broke people out
there have an opinion about money all
kinds of fat people have a lot of
opinions about nutrition - oh yeah yes
there's no way I understand you can't
lose weight you got a thing for cookies
I got it no I mean nobody duct-tapes you
to your bed and force-feed your
cheesecake you just decide to eat it me
too baby me - I got it I mean it's
Christmas time lord help us all right
but the truth is son if you want it if
you want to save up and pay cash for the
house anybody makes fun of you just wink
at them smile nod your head and walk
away you haven't found a wise person yet
I suspect if you find a couple of old
rich people you're 23 so olds anybody
over 30 but I'm talking really old like
over 40 or over 60 maybe somebody that's
60 years old or older and got money and
you tell them what your goal is you know
what most of them will tell you son
that's a great goal that's a really good
idea let's see what those people are
they're people that are successful in
their winters and you know whiners you
usually encourage other people to win
losers usually encourage other people to
lose there's more of them they're
everywhere
she just kind of got to think through
and consider the source and just wink
and go yeah
Yeah right don't think so really the
point is don't try to argue with a loser
because you know they'll drag you down
and and beat you with their lose Ernest
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]